this one is wild it's just it's just
such an assault on sanity this is a
Woman by the name of Nadi akamoto she is
the CEO of a feminine products company
called August and apparently she's
making products for anyone who bleeds
out of there anywhere take a look
history and Society has built up the
stigma that makes menstruators feel so
ashamed yeah it makes us feel like
there's something wrong with our bodies
we're taught that period blood is this
contaminable like disgusting
yes and I think that it always breaks my
heart to hear so many stories every day
of young menstrators who get their
period and have never heard about it
right this is a good conversation for
boys my son is now 35 but when he was 11
or 12 I sent him at the store to buy a
product he's like ew yeah and I thought
that's the wrong reaction yes it is the
story go by some pads
it's just another product
no but that's what we have to change
that's the problem yeah that's the
problem we have to change that some pads
if you must know but we so I guess to me
is the result of spending years in the
space identifying pain points whether
they be around sustainability like I
grew up hating pads most pads have
enough plastic for like three to five
plastic bags right so very scratchy very
comfortable but also wanting a period
positive gender inclusive brand so we
are August wanting a gender exclusive
name on the back it says we're here for
everyone who menstruates and I think
especially in this age of transphobia it
really means a lot to us to be proudly a
gender inclusive brand but everything
about the product we try to be super
thoughtful about from uh how we design
it to be as comfortable as absorbent as
possible but also as sustainable as
possible so yeah so with the water I'm
not sure what's happening here I get to
do a fun little you know we're living in
this one
yeah
good that's good we are living in a
society although I'm not sure for how
much longer that's George Costanza for
you the guys are testing out some fun
little things
um that woman wants to have a period
positive gender inclusive tampon
now I'm in the studio right now with the
three guys there's three of you right
there and I'm a guy
just by a show of hands guys is anyone
here bleeding from their vagina right
now
Brock actually looked down makes you
wonder makes you wonder uh you cannot
bleed from your vagina if you don't have
a vagina okay this has nothing to do
with transphobia although if a man
walked up to me on the street and said
my vagina's bleeding can you help me I
would be a little bit afraid I really
would be although I don't think that
would be a phobia because a phobia is an
irrational fear and if a dude walked up
to me picture a 6'4 dude runs up to you
my vagina's bleeding help me
I would I would have a legitimate fear
of that person so it's not even a phobia
they're just wrong about everything
[Music]